bonjour généralement si bon jour mais
heureuse gueuleton bonjour à tous les
auditeurs de martine première vous êtes
membre du secrétariat de nos peuples est
en charge du projet politique du
mouvement et vous êtes aussi
généralement six candidats dans la
circonscription du nord atlantique les
législatives pour nous placer forcé ou
bien c'est une si grande évidence que
cela non c'est une suite logique de
notre engagement depuis 2015 la date de
notre création nous sommes efforcés de
forger un projet politique en
concertation et avec la participation de
la population
ce projet politique nous l'avons portée
lors des élections pour la ctm avec le
succès que vous connaissez et puisque
vous pouviez fusionner au deuxième tour
avec d'autres formations politiques si
vous aviez refusé
nous avions refusé parce que nous ne
retrouvions pas dans les programmes qui
étaient proposés et surtout dans la
vision pour la martinique que ses autres
candidats proposés alors juin 2010 cette
législative vous y allez avec quelle
prétention rappelle qu' il y avoue dans
le centre atlantique marcellin nadeau
dans le nord et jérémy ferdinand dans le
sud
en effet tous nos candidats sont
investis d'une mission c'est celui de
porter les valeurs de nos peuples à des
valeurs vous savez qu'ils s'engagent
autour de la question de l'écologie de
la transformation sociale de notre pays
et c'est ça la différence que nous
portons avec les autres candidats
dans cet espace d'expression de
communication pour vous cette
législative s'est décollée s'organise
mais aussi un espace d'expression mais
c'est surtout un objectif de gagner les
différentes circonscriptions de manière
à porter plus loin notre projet
politique
il ya encore un flou concernant la
circonscription de fort de france
pourquoi pléthore de candidats ou une
question cela vaut-il le coup d'y aller
face à serge letchimy non pas du tout
notre assemblée générale a décidé d'être
présent sur l'ensemble des
circonscriptions laisser les secteurs
avaient
des dates pour proposer des candidats la
section de fort de france n'a pas encore
réussi à se mettre d'accord sur un
candidat y encore des débats et nous
leur avons laissé un temps pour trouver
le candidat idéal où la candidate idéale
sur cet ajustement fait bien deux
candidates lorsque vous prenez la parité
hommes femmes en politique est pour
l'instant sur quatre circonscriptions il
ya trois hommes peut-être de liste c'est
vrai il ya trois hommes tête de liste
mais il ya aussi des suppléants qui
seront des femmes
nous attachons une importance
particulière à ça et puis sur fond de
grand bassam et pourquoi pas deux femmes
à têtes de liste parce que pour qu'il y
ait des femmes il faut qu'elle soit
candidate
et c'est vrai que nous n'avons pas eu
d'initier des deux femmes qui se sont
portées candidates pour être alors
d'être là prône un discours mais
n'arrivent pas quand même à séduire
n'est suffisamment de candidates sont
vraiment dans une logique d'implication
des femmes elle souhaite aussi avoir
plus d'informations plus le temps de jeu
vous rappelle que nous peuple a été créé
en 2015 et il fait que beaucoup de
militants avaient déjà une expérience et
sa pas été le cas d'un certain nombre de
femmes qui souhaitent encore qu'on leur
donne un temps pour pour pouvoir
participer pleinement aux élections nous
peuple est une condition de
personnalités venant de formations
politiques associatives de la vie civile
il ya on entendu tout à l'heure dans
l'édition de sept heures de la première
il ya le cncp avec l'équipe autour de
jean à bol qui vous fait les yeux doux à
l'occasion de sa rentrée politique et il
faut pouvoir peser et toutes ces
formations politiques qui viennent avec
vous ça peut compter alors nous paie
plat on l'a souvent dit n'est pas une
coalition d'organisations politiques
vous avez déjà effectivement qui sont
encartés dans cette information et qui
viennent à titre individuel à nous
peuple a et c'est vrai que pas mal de
militants du cncp ont choisi de
rejoindre à trith individuel notre
organisation le mouvement citoyen une
paix plat avec à côté d'eux des
personnes issues de la société civile du
mouvement associatif du mouvement
syndical ou des gens comme vous et moi
qui ont souhaité à un moment de leur vie
s'impliquer dans la vie citoyenne
mais justement c'est ça la nouveauté est
apparemment le cncp voeux en tant que
formation venir vers vous
et ça risque pas de bouleverser un peu
la donne dans votre conception de cncp
affirmé son soutien à la démarche
entreprise par nos plats et je crois que
toutes les organisations qui voudront
nous affirme un tel soutien seront les
bienvenus alors j'ai entraînement si le
centre atlantique certainement la
circonscription qui semble aujourd'hui
la plus ouverte depuis l'annnonce
d'alfred marie-jeanne de ne pas être
candidat à sa propre succession vous
ferez campagne sur le bilan du sortant
écoutez non le monsieur marie jeanne ne
se représente pas et c'est c'est à lui
de faire son bilan devant les personnes
qui l'ont élu vous savez nous on est
dans une logique totalement différente
de celle des infra de marie-jeanne
alfred marie jeanne se présente lui-même
comme un bon gestionnaire
quelqu'un qui a peut être les clés pour
gérer une collectivité
nous on n'est pas dans cette logique
nous ne sommes pas dans une logique de
gestion qui nous nous intéresse pas de
gérer le système ce qui nous intéresse
c'est de le transformer j'avais le
système vous dites on est dans une
logique de transformation sociale c'est
à dire de faire en sorte que la majorité
de la population puisse se reconnaître
et trouver leur intérêt dans les
politiques qui sont menées
c'est pas ce qu'a fait ce qu'a défendu
alfred marie-jeanne et à l'assemblée
nationale mais nous c'est la logique
qu'on veut porter au sein de 7 alors
comment vous vous y prendrez alors si
vous ne faites pas le bilan du sortant
faisait proposez quoi ou leurs habitants
se confirma le bilan du sortant mais
c'est vrai que il ya un certain nombre
de personnalités qui se présentent sur
cette circonscription et qui se réclame
en tout cas de la majorité ou qui sont
dans les faits dans la majorité
d'alfred marie-jeanne donc il faudra
qu'ils disent finalement qu'est ce qui a
été positif dans cette mandature puisque
ils sont dans ce camp-là non nous ce qui
nous intéresse c'est d'investir toutes
les dimensions du mandat de députée
mandat de député il ya une dimension
internationale il faut qu'on soit que la
martinique s'ouvre au monde soit
présente sur le monde et donc nous
soutiendra députés celui qui vote les
lois c'est celui qui vote les lois mais
le député il a
une autorité il a investi d'une mission
il faut qu'ils aient une vision pour son
pays
il faut qu'ils fassent partager cette
vision avec la population avec le peuple
martiniquais
il faut qu ils le défendent partout dans
les institutions à l'assemblée nationale
dans les ministères mais aussi au plan
international parce que la martinique
est là quelque chose à faire au monde
elle doit s'inscrire dans la marche du
monde on doit faire le lien entre nos
propres combats entre nos propres
projets et puis comment ils peuvent
s'articuler aux projets qui sont
développés par les autres nations
c'est vrai vous avez des choses
formidables qui se développe l'europe
n'est plus le centre du monde au brésil
des banques solidaires en asie les
systèmes de financement participatif la
lutte contre le franc cfa et pour une
monnaie panafricaine en afrique
tous ces mouvements là nous intermarché
nique et doivent être en voie d'être
attentif il y aura des débats sur les
relations entre l'europe entre la france
et toutes ces régions du monde et nous
devons y prendre notre entière par la
démarche gérard tellement si la démarche
de nos places et que vous irez devant la
population de cette circonscription du
centre atlantique et essayer d'établir
un programme en commun vous ira ensuite
à l'assemblée nationale pour dire voilà
ce que nous voulons pour notre part
notre martinique ce que nous prévoyons
de faire c'est effectivement nous avons
un socle programmatique et celui de nou
pé plat et que nous défendons tout au
long de l'année
rappelez vous l'année qui vient de
s'écouler nous avons mené le débat
politique sur la question de la
transition énergétique
ces nouvelles plaques y apposer la
difficulté le problème la nécessité de
sortir du tout pétrole de développer des
énergies à zéro émission carbone c'est
une plaque qui était sur ce débat là sur
le droit de vivre et de travailler au
pays
nous avons défendu ce principe sur des
cas concrets le nous peuple a été au
coeur du débat politique sur la question
on en parlait tout à l'heure du
fonctionnement des institutions
encore là nous avons posé le problème et
je crois que un député à l'assemblée
nationale il devrait effectivement
proposé soit des amendements soit un
texte pour faire en sorte que le
fonctionnement de la ctm s'améliore ce
combat seulement six élus à l'assemblée
nationale vous proposez vous proposerez
une refonte de ce fonctionnement de la
ctm
absolument parce qu'on voit les limites
du fonctionnement cet accord vise par
exemple
non parce que claude lise a un problème
avec marie jeanne et il met ça sur le
dos du fonctionnement et de la façon
dont ces qui exactement ce qu'il dit
mais on observe et nous voyons et y
compris les universitaires qui la
critiquaient tout à l'heure et qui font
un travail sérieux c'est leur rôle aussi
d'analyser la manière dont fonctionnent
les institutions et ben c'est
universitaire ils disent qu'on n'a pas
investi pleinement le fonctionnement de
la ctm et alors ce jeu avant de avant de
de revoir c'est ces institutions il ya
aussi la question la question même du
vote pour cette institution
je crois que il faut introduire la
proportionnelle intégrale ou au minimum
baisser le labri la prime qu'il est
offerte
quel regard avez-vous sur le travail de
nos députés dans l'ensemble on constate
que beaucoup d'amendements sont proposés
beaucoup sont surtout rejeter les
martiniquais ne savent pas travailler
ensemble et parlementaires de notre île
ne savent pas travailler ensemble
contrairement à ce qui se passe par
exemple à la réunion ou peut-être même
en guadeloupe
non mais vous voyez ce qui se passe pour
être cohérent il faut avoir un projet
politique un projet pour son pays une
vision et c'est ensuite qu'on voit quels
sont les textes quelles sont les lois
qui sont en mesure de permettre les
conditions de réunir les conditions pour
l'émergence d'un tel projet comme n'y a
pas de projet et évidemment ça tombe à
plat
et puis il faut faire attention quand on
est député
il faut proposer des textes qui relève
de la loi quand un député propose quand
le député propose un amendement pour
autoriser un médicament il sait
pertinemment que ça relève pas de la loi
mais du pouvoir réglementaire
moi à la place de ses députés qu'est ce
que j'aurais fait puisque c'est un
médicament que produisent les cubains je
serais allé voir les cubains je leur
avais dit bah voilà pour distribuer un
médicament en france
il faut une autorisation de mise sur le
marché et bien réunis sont les
conditions
pour faire en sorte que et trouvons les
partenaires sur place pour que ce
médicament puisse être diffusé en mars à
travers cet exemple rappelle vous êtes
cadre l agence régionale de santé
il faut faire forcément partie de grands
groupes pour qu'on puisse peser lors
d'une prise de décision
nos plats avec des députés si j'aurais
ou à droite à gauche
vous savez bien qu'on sait j'aurai pas à
droite sinon la question non refaire
leur vie dans la tour être dans la santé
un grand groupe
dans l'assemblée vous avez toujours
toujours un groupe qui rassemble des
personnels des personnalités qui propose
des modes de travail alternatif qui sont
des progressistes et qui se rassemblent
parce qu'ils ne se reconnaissent pas
dans une des grandes formations autour
du parti socialiste ou autour des
républicains généralement si mercier
rappelle que vous êtes membre du
secrétariat de nou pé plat et en charge
du projet politique et de se mouvoir
merci bonne journée merci bonne journée
à tous les auditeurs